hello everyone and welcome to round four
of this year's norway chess and to the
match you've all been waiting for it's
world champion magnus carlsen versus
world chess championship challenger
yanni pomnishi and uh their classical
game uh was not all that impressive it
ended in a draw it was a very tedious
berlin defense and as soon as everyone
saw that it was a brilliant no one was
expecting all that much uh even though
that there was that game in the
candidates tournament if you remember uh
between uh levon and and vladimir
kramnik that had a beautiful g5 and
started just a you know uh crazy attack
but that was the berlin uh with queens
on the board this was the the the usual
berlin where uh you you go for fast uh
draws uh and we're not gonna be showing
that one so this is the armageddon game
uh magnus has the white pieces and of
course the seven minutes versus ten
minutes so let's see what happens uh and
uh uh who will who will win this
encounter so magnus with the white
pieces opens with knight to f3 he
decides to mix it up a little bit not
going for another berlin uh we have
knight to f6 uh so diretti opening is on
the board g3 we have d5 bishop to g2 and
g6 by nipple so we're in the king's
indian attack the yugoslav variation we
have castles and now bishop to g7
we have c4 by magnus and now c6
defending the d5 pawn we have b3
preparing bishop to b2 to counter
black's bishop on this diagonal and now
knight to e for opening up an attack
against carlson's rook here so of course
we're going to play d4 we're going to
block this and now nipple just castles
with bishop to b2 and now there are a
lot of possible and popular moves here
for black such as knight to d7 bishop to
f5 also very popular but nipple goes for
a5 it's uh a little
less played but still a very strong move
uh magnus just continues knights the c3
also keeps on uh keeps an eye on the a4
square if nepal decides to push it even
further we have bishop to f5 continuing
development and now e3 uh so we have
knight captures on c3 bishop captures
and now bishop to e4 and black can be
very happy with his position here he
still has some development to do but um
he has a firm grip on the position we
have queen to e2 magnus develops the
queen connects the rooks and now a4 now
as planned we have rook f to c1 by
magnus if c captures on d5 then the c
file might open up at some at some point
and the light square bishop might also
be very useful on this diagonal so eight
captures on b3 a captures on b3 and now
rook captures on a1 we have rook
captures on a1 and now there is one game
or maybe even two games where c5 was
played but here in nepal plays queen to
b6 and it is now only as of move 15 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see how magnus continues well magnus
continues with the strongest possible
move you can play with white in any
given position and that is of course
pawn to b4 so he plays pawn to b4 as the
pawn on b3 was attacked and now he's
preparing c5 and nipple should really do
something about this uh for example he
should maybe capture on c4 and after
queen captures and then maybe bishop to
d5 further harass the queen maybe force
a queen trade with queen to c5 and so on
uh but instead he continues developing
knight to d7 and this allows magnus to
grab a little uh too much space here on
the queen side magnus plays c5 and now
what do you play here uh you can't
really go some like queen to b5 to try
and trade queens like this because after
captures captures your pawn structure is
just terrible completely ruined rooked
a7 and the white is just
enjoying his dominant position so nippo
decided to go back queen to c7 and now
rook to a7 so
allowing this uh b4c5 idea is basically
giving magnus something to do in this
position so queen to b8 he doesn't want
to allow this b pawn to be pinned and
also the rook is now attacked and now
queen to a2 defending the rook and also
preparing queen to a5 which will be very
useful if the knight ever moves you can
shift the queen to b6 put more pressure
on the b7 pawn uh and now nipple uh uh
not to do anything crazy he just has to
not do anything for example i move like
bishop to d3
is very nice it doesn't really do all
that much but it's a nice move also move
like h5 uh just grabbing more space on
the king side is a very nice move but he
goes for the forcing bishop captures on
f3 and this kind of uh helps magnus as
his knight here wasn't really doing all
that much and this will very nicely
activate this uh this light square
bishop as you'll see uh nipple strikes
in the center with e5 and now magnus
grabs more space here with b5 the thread
being b captures on c6 and then black
will not be able to recapture as the
knight is hanging here so here uh what
do you do you should capture on d4
that's probably the best course of
action after bishop captures the bishop
captures pawn captures now you continue
playing this game where okay this is
still in the position but now we can
move knight to f6 and if captures then
we can capture
however nipple here played e4 and this
is now a problem magnus played bishop
back to e2 and now what do you do if you
play knight to f6 now it's not not a lot
of fun queen to a5 and we're still gonna
play queen to b6 and it's gonna be uh
it's gonna be just ugly defending this
position with black so nipple instead
tried knight captures on c5 as you can
see if pawn captures then bishop
captures bishop on c3 but the disallows
magnus a very very
uh silent move but a deadly one so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find this move while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well uh
not not an incredibly elusive move but
it's not you know incredibly easy to
spot and for those who just want to
enjoy the show it's of course bishop to
b4 always there when there's something
good the b4 square is involved so now uh
the knight is still being threatened but
uh there is no bishop on c3 for the
black bishop to capture
so what do you play if you move the
knight you will lose the the rook here
but there's nothing better if you don't
do anything you're just going to be down
a piece so here knights the a6 kind of
disconnecting the queen's defense of the
rook on a7 also now maybe the queen
captures an a7 can be played but magnus
just plays bishop captures on f8 and now
if queen captures an a7 uh we're up a
piece bishop captures on g7 king
captures and b captures on a6 there is
no point in playing this we're up a
bishop in our position is is just great
so after bishop captures an f8 we have
bishop captures by nippo and now rook
captures on b7 by magnus you could play
something like b6 to keep keep the rook
but magnus says there's no need i have
more than enough here to win the game
queen captures on b7 now queen captures
on a6 and of course black here cannot
trade queens if captures captures
there's no stopping this past pawn
this bishop is too slow uh to
prevent the pawn from reaching the a7
that's a dark square and this route is a
bit too long as the white pawn only
requires two moves the queen so instead
after queen captures an a6 we have queen
to beat by nipple and now queen captures
on c6 grabbing yet another pawn
so now magnus is not only equalized in
material but is also up upon but it's a
very very dangerous pass pawn here for
example b6 b7 queen to see it and it's
game over there's no defense against
this so nipple starts with queen to d6
it is the only option he wants to go
into the opposite color bishop end game
and try and hold this to a draw and the
magnus says not a problem uh let's let's
let's do it but we have queen captures
on d6 bishop captures and now it's not
all that intense as the d5 uh and the e4
pawns are on light squares and the nippo
is unable to defend them so magnus
simply prepares to attack the base of
the pawn chain bishop to d1 preparing
bishop b3 and then bishop captures on d5
so here we have bishop to c7 uh keeping
an eye on the b6 square now bishop to b3
we have kink to g7 bishop captures on d5
grabbing that pawn and now f5 so now
nipple has four pawns here in a very
nice chain magnus has six pawns and
he will of course try to escort at least
one of uh one of them up the board but
it's not going to be easy nipples dark
square bishop is guarding the b6 square
and also the d6 square those are dark
squares and without the help of the
white king there's really no hope for
you uh to cross that so magnus starts by
ruining nepo's beautiful pawn chain and
that's g4 going after the pawn here uh
we have king to f6 and now h4 you have
to further uh further attack the pawn
chain we have h6 and now king to g2 uh
we have bishop to d8 uh waiting move
waiting for magnus to make a mistake so
now h5 by magnus further um undermining
this this pawn chain and now you have to
start grabbing something so f captures
in g4 now h captures on g6 uh what do
you play here nipple plays king captures
on g6 now bishop captures an e4 and now
after king to g5 we have f4 with check
here magnus is hoping for captures on f3
alpaca and then after king captures you
will have three pass pawn here's of
course that will be completely winning
and you don't really have to worry about
this pawn the bishop covers the h1
square forever there's no stopping that
so after f4 check nipple went back king
to f6 now comes king to g3 attacking the
pawn and nepo defends it with h5 uh we
have king the h4 going after the spawn
and now one last uh trick attempt from
nepo that's a bishop to a5 here he's
hoping for magnus to capture the pawn on
h5 and if he does so then we can play
bishop to d2 and start going after these
pawns that are on dark squares but
magnus doesn't even allow this here
magnus just pushed his pawn to b6 uh he
sacrifices this pawn this will leave him
with three pawns against the zero pawns
as the white king will pick up all of
the pawns on the king side and there is
nothing for black to do here
so it was in this position on move 41
that ianni pony should resign to the
game and magnus wins the match not in
the classical but in the in the
armageddon uh we'll see if nipple will
be able to retaliate when he gets the
white pieces in their next game uh here
and maybe he will even be able to do it
in the classical section so yeah we'll
see what happens uh but yeah here there
is no hope if you don't capture the pawn
then just b7 b8 and if you capture it
then the
uh well there's just nothing for black
to do you're to capture this pawn and
now the bishop is too far away there's
no saving this pawn if g3 we're just
going to go after it there there's no
defense here
uh and of course the g2 square is
covered by the by the viral light square
bishop uh so after b6 nipple resigned
and magnus wins this on move 41 just
when they reached time control
uh so yeah a very nice game uh by both
of them the classical game was
incredibly incredibly precise uh so if
you guys want to check it out to do do
check it out but uh you know i i i
we have a habit here kind of not to show
too many berlin defenses if there's
absolutely nothing going on there of
course there's something going on just
nothing that we could follow uh so yeah
uh once again hope you enjoyed this
armageddon game i would like to thank
samuel kamui mikhail garber john queenie
matthew coleman and rupert hipkins for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
other matches from this event checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day